[Music]
the siren wales
and seconds later the first of several
cluster bomb strikes
rips down the street
each a collection of mini explosions
saturating the air with killer shrapnel
the people of nagorno-karabakh's capital
stepanakert have suffered multiple
rocket and artillery attacks in recent
weeks
international charity the halo trust is
here to keep track
and prepare for its teams to come and
remove explosive debris
when the fighting dies down they'll come
and do
a full clearance of this area a visual
bac we call it battle area clearance
clearance of this area checking for any
unexploded items
and then destroying them almost in situ
because
these items cannot be moved they cannot
be touched
and they can land anywhere such as
buried in the mud inside this chicken
coop
another one for the clearance teams the
danger
is that anyone could pick them up either
because they don't recognize the latest
weapons or because they want to move
them out of the city
which is exactly what's happened here so
here we have
a collection of different munitions most
of them
the ones with the red ribbons are
cluster bomblets that fell
on stepanakers and they've been brought
here by local residents who
physically pick them up and put them in
a box any one of them
could have exploded so one of the halo
trusts other jobs here is going from
street to street
to homes and bomb shelters warning
people of the dangers
they look very nice attractive when you
see it
it's like a toy you want to play with
but it's dangerous
yesterday we've been in a 300 shelters
speaking to about 600 people
we want to talk to as many as possible
to tell them
these are dangerous things
before the recent fighting started late
last month halo was dealing with
unexploded bombs and mines from the
first nagorno-karabakh war of the early
90s
people here are still losing life and
limb to them
now charity workers and stepanakert's
weary inhabitants
have a whole new wars worth to contend
with
rory challenge al jazeera stepanakert
nagorno-karabakh